hi YouTube I would like to answer to
please our young I agree absolutely with
what you're saying and I wanted to ask
you if you have ever looked at Wikipedia
I don't that project six years ago and I
join it because I wanted to communicate
with others and work with others and
what I discovered is a place where
people will recreate community and I
work together to create content and make
this content available to all the other
ones and what is very interesting if you
really join us community we discover
that many of our editors are very young
people we have people as young as 14
years old we have many 17 18 years old
so they could be my children and they
teach me a lot of things and while stay
out content we keep it out not only
today feel empowered to do it and to
teach others what they know but they
also learn from others and they learn a
lot of new skills such as collaboration
they know learn how to deal with others
different are different people from
other nations and all other countries
and this is an absolute great place for
me to discover life so I would really
suggest that you go and look and maybe
try to lead some children to join
Wikipedia so that's I thank you